I think compassion is is not expecting
people to be more advanced than they are
and and that's what people have done
with me I mean when I went to the asham
and when I spent up with these monks I
mean I am in no way and even now I'm not
I mean they're compassionate even to
spend time with me now and and I feel
like when you've experienced that level
of compassion where people see you they
look through your soul they watch you
and they just think they can see
everything about you that you don't like
about yourself mhm and they will still
find that spark of potential and the
spark that makes them believe that we
should invest and serve and help this
human being and for me when you've
experience that level of
compassion even if you are still dealing
with stuff yourself you want to pass it
on and so when I see anyone at any level
I don't judge anyone because hey hey
I've been there before hey I'm still
there kind of in some ways and I know
how hard it is to get out of that mess
and so how can I judge someone just
because they're three steps behind